з отримання штати в ж формує нову
стратегію дівчини донбасу та вашингтон 5
3 травня територіальну цілісність
україни не тільки на словах а і наділимо
процес заявив глава української
делегації вранці прихильник він так не круто
рахунки донбасу
але немає кравчук в одному з інтерв'ю
українським змієм chase правді ново
адміністрація байдена ж розпушує
такі плани ще проц і думають за океан і
новий формат для донбасу
досвіду не dv американські експерти
підтвердили читець отримання штати та
9 в трампі незабаром 2 знач насті
удон панського харчування a la tribu
образа підходить і до зміни
нормандського формату на гілці дата і
воїни на мага тис нагайна заміні води
cool і хиталася а вина на донбасі
чарльза куб чан противагу
соняшником президента США бараку
обами юпи кого вся європейська і справа
ми sug рамою україну я часто бував у
ківі то москві
туди було два паралельні напрямки
норманський формат і двостороннє від
ресторані переговорами з shop україною та
росією
монопод на зубці та c продовження роботи
у c2 на плівках норманський процес та
американський
інша опція обговорення з францією
негайну Україну це росії
можливості з створення шорсткого формату
розум тут США за столом проговоримо
закласти готовності путіна пити на
компроміс так погода тис на припаяні
та конфлікту
чим же дасть відібрати його розуміння і
готовності на відома червоним ми знаємо і що
путін у розливай за раз через пізнання
навального to protest і налякати його
історія свічки що підлога і шляхи 2 год.
в розливаємо vin коду з і б крутим
хлопцем за кордоном
нове-2 хрестову за зовнішню політику для
підр ще не про свою внутрішню
популярності store
детально збрую так чонін з отримання
штати продовжать вир над ватою україною
економічну савицьку допомогу ключ
на зло таємну бровою прасок поганий
кулачний посол США в Україні
кар'єрний дипломат стивен пайпер 3 рок
це міст отримали штати продав та українці
210 ракет то 37 проти танкових
комплексів java len колір був осі за
президентство дональда трампу
адміністрації його папороті бараку
обами не склалося, а націй коло за рахунок
припливу валу і байденом таки в результаті booba
віце-президентом нині жердини воші
господарем білоху будинку
байден то й рік дуже вже активно
виступають за треба не українці летальну
зброї в одні з вас стане телефонним
розмах із києвом дір секретарка ентоні
блінкін заявивши про готовність порубати їм
видасть брови її псих і поставок інакше
деталей покер та розвал ошиваються
технічний потік 2 як розмінна монета
ось нас головних ділимо для байдена поважаючи
пфр ланцюга особистий шлях ic2
але в адміністрації США правильної видно
ви ти трансатлантичні партнерськими
дно сіни з євросоюзом засіки з берліном
таких ці потрималася за частиною трампом
теж експерти не вимикають 3 сторонні
будинки влади в газову трубу
підемо міністрація байдена не хочу
воювати з берліном через первинний шлях
до 2
он і хоче but i важливі вам та партнерам
і теж я ще в дасть розрубати і так все
росіян і завищувати донбаса США
слово боці
знімуть санкції з первинної стелі 2cb
labs прийнято за , але санкції проти
первинного потоку 2 на для того щоб
шеф з карате росію
піднімають досі політичних силою і
відлік з приємним і там ще кинь я
завищувала донбас even in der зовсім назад
в україну
c-block харн і вдома владою джипі дано
з москва
поки неясно а обличчі тієї 500 джордж це і
мить біда допомогла тиліда
morel шукала ті ж у сні за словом
та старшого експерта атлантичної ради
аріеля до і на ці родом з кримом you
важливості жид на заході і ми в україні між
вашингтоном і берліном і консенсус з
диво б заспівати це стабільності україни
la нею знаки можн його очах гострими
ситуації на донбасі на сні ваша is
in an easy
дефект росія перебуваючи у складні
економічніше ситуації так вже ряд
працювати а протестував і щоб виду алек ти
увагу кремль можеш пробувати і росах
це ти з ранку труби ти
гареджі чаю буду велика вина я не
думаю що затікала не сша ризикувати і з
росію
відомо не з краще не штати
займаються
до видну криту та інші ми внутрішніми
проблемами та китай нині головний
пріоритет для адміністрації байдену алое
українському уряду то весь до вас у роті
but i підготовленими так можна ви
ескалації на вас не
з кліщ нсп поспішаю кадри потім стратегія
про оформлена та затвор джону нову
стратегію захисту донбасом поки що габарити
перед сном та в адміністрації байдена
лише 64 тисячі при владі або пучок а
ти поки що його 100 точність формується
команда байдена я call пік у цьому цьому
українським харчуванням засіки добрими вдома
в Україні дипломатка вікторію нуланд ми
пройшли по садах заступника держа
секретаря з політичних справа all ще
не затвердів і проблем сем зайшла ми
експерти в ньому а йому ти че призначає з
США новий спецприз але dhd майже до
україни я calais бугурт волкер
вашингтоні члени ви значилося am alive
ж навчав і дно ще з отримали штати за
президентства байдена акти зовні прямо
там якщо україну mvp на не досвіду немає
американські експерти його рота учнів
цієї більше газу краще не США та ви
рішення поспішаючи
тумба з кого харчування а шляху мені
кримською